we're less than three full months into
the into 2018 but the number of working
legislative days for Congress is
dwindling there are still two hundred
eighty five days left on the 2018
calendar but the house will only be in
session for eighty eight of those days
in the Senate just 126 days Julianna
Goldman is on Capitol Hill with whether
lawmakers will be able to keep their
legislative promises in that short time
Julianna good morning good morning well
that might seem like a long bit of time
but don't expect much legislating during
that period after this spending bill
which does include some modest measures
on tough issues like guns there's little
motivation to take further action before
November's midterm elections we're gonna
pass the stop school violence ban bump
stocks and make it a crime to possess or
manufacture them while members of both
parties are calling for urgent action on
an array of issues the key thing at this
point for us is not just protecting our
elections from future Russian intrusion
it's protecting our elections period I
hope we can do an infrastructure bill
it's unlikely they'll be able to tick
through their wish list before the
November midterm elections let us do our
job and move forward it's harder to get
bipartisan consensus these days and get
those bills that everyone kind of agrees
are a good idea past because of the
level of vitriol michael steele was the
spokesman for former House Speaker John
Boehner and says whenever it passes the
spending bill will likely be the last
major legislative action this year given
the lack of harmony and bipartisanship
in Washington these days there aren't a
lot of other opportunities for big
bipartisan bills the midterm elections
are on the minds of many with upwards of
50 competitive races Democrats need to
pick up 24 seats in the House and two in
the Senate to take a majority in both
chambers and despite a major victory on
taxes we passed the largest tax cuts and
reform in American history we all know
Washington is broken
Republicans will face challengers who
decry inaction in Washington sentiment
echoed by Republican senator Susan
Collins who this week warned against not
moving on legislation to lower health
care premiums
the focus is on scoring partisan
political points that can be used in the
fall elections lawmakers are about to
leave for a two-week recess and now
typically we don't really see this
slowdown until August of an election
year but this year the schedule is a bit
out of whack because of the way Congress
has been passing these short-term
smaller spending bills gale
a lot of things seem out of whack in
Washington these days thank you very
much Julianna